um Bobby Kennedy Jr recently appeared on
Bill Maher's podcast the clubhouse
we now have the opportunity to hear
directly from him what is his view about
vaccines Bill Maher confronted him not
really Bill Maher told him I basically
agree with you about vaccines but you're
not handling this correctly you're gonna
have to defend your position so we now
have video of Bobby Kennedy explaining
his views on vaccines he always says I'm
not anti-vaxx I just want safe vaccines
but you will very quickly see in this
video that his views are simply not
based in fact let's get right into it on
the side that shows that autism is
caused by vaccines there's over 100
studies
I in fact did a book in which I listed
all of those studies
and digested in other words summarize
them all and you can go and Source them
okay this is a classic anti-vaxx line
there's a hundred studies that find a
link between vaccines and autism there's
a hundred studies and people accept it
uncritically the folks that have fallen
for this who by the way are mostly
right-wing folks it's a whole
interesting thing Trump is now praising
Bobby Kennedy Jr his constituency is
heavily made up of Maga people he should
probably be running as a republican
quite frankly but let's not do
someone like Bobby goes 100 studies link
vaccines to autism and then someone
hears it and repeats it uh you can
actually investigate that okay there is
not any scientific evidence that links
vaccines to autism and in fact on the
contrary many Studies have found no link
whatsoever the foremost such quote study
by now disbarred doctor to revoked
medical license Andrew Wakefield was
retracted it's a bogus study most of the
data that many people cite comes from
that but let's talk about this hundred
studies thing the claim that more than
100 studies link vaccines to autism is
based on a list of papers that was
compiled by an anti-vaxx website they
have a horse in the game in the race so
to speak and the list has been widely
debunked by experts now don't take my
word for it do what Bobby says go and
look at the list but don't just look at
the summaries that he makes look at the
actual uh citations okay many of the
papers on the list aren't actually about
vaccines and autism at all they might be
about one or the other
some have been retracted
some have methodological flaws and some
simply theorize about what could cause
autism if you look at those hundred
papers you will find papers that for
example say when we think about why
there may be rising rates of autism one
reason could be that we are better at
diagnosing it so we're actually just
identifying more cases of autism another
reason could be vaccines another reason
could be you know whatever Wi-Fi right
just because you put vaccines on a list
of things that hypothetically could be
related doesn't mean that it's a study
that shows it this is the sort of stuff
he's citing tons of examples there's one
paper called a positive Association
found
between Autism prevalence and childhood
vaccination and it claims to show that
there's a correlation between
vaccination rates and autism in
different states the idea being states
with more vaccination also have more
autism the problem is it doesn't
establish any causal link it's not
science it doesn't account for the fact
that autism diagnosis is likely better
in the very same states that have more
vaccination I'll give you an example and
I don't want to beat a dead horse here
uh I apologize for the the violent term
beating a dead horse but it's it's
really important to understand this
think about the states that have higher
rates of vaccination
okay think about the states that have
better health infrastructure
okay if you think about those States
California New York Connecticut
Massachusetts
that have better health infrastructure
are going to find and diagnose more
autism because they actually have
protocols for when teachers observe
certain behaviors you would actually say
hey this is someone who maybe should be
screened for autism etc those are the
same states that have higher vaccination
rates due to Better Health
infrastructure and better education so
this is just one example and you can go
through and you can find it it's a bogus
list on the also important to note the
very pediatrician that Bobby Kennedy
cites for much of his anti-vaccine views
has disavowed Bobby Kennedy and says he
interviewed me once and then completely
misstated all the stuff I said
so that's another Classic on the other
hand we have the work of the CDC uh
National Academy of Medicine all these
groups that say we we've looked at it we
find absolutely no link between vaccines
and autism okay it gets crazier from
there let's continue remember this is
Bobby Kennedy in his own words giving us
his view about vaccine says 100 studies
find a link that's a debunked list many
of the studies don't even actually deal
with that issue let's continue over 450
uh
450 studies summarize and I have 1400
citations the questions for your
campaign is I'm not talking about this
stuff on my campaign I'm just talking
between you and that's a ridiculous
Assumption of course you're going to
have to talk about YouTube somebody
asked me I'm going to they're all going
to ask you are you seriously we're going
to ask you about the you think they're
there for your friends who want to help
you no they're going on they want to go
to the most vulnerable point which is
because you don't believe in vaccines
that's not me talking no I don't believe
that
I
I believe you are more
um
I just believe in science I I understand
but you know any genre of the science
yeah but let's not talk about again the
science that's the thing that's the
mistake they made I believe in science
yes
let me just say this we have different
every medicine is required to duplicate
controlled trials that's what science is
you give you you give a group of people
a cohorted people
the medicine
and then you give the pla a simile
situation situated cohort of people the
placebo
and then you will get health outcomes
over a four or five year period because
many of the impact of the outcomes
are going to have long diagnostic
Horizons along incubation periods so you
won't see them immediately you need to
do it Anthony found you just said eight
years for vaccine
you need to watch them for a while
those Studies have not the only medicine
that never gets tested are vaccines okay
so let's talk about that this they
believe that this is their sort of trump
card right that this is irrefutable he
says we we need these placebo-controlled
vaccine trials this is a common ruse
with these folks okay it is true that
the specific autism vaccine link has not
been extensively explored with regard to
child vaccinations through that
particular type of type of trial but why
not the why not is extraordinarily
important to understand the reason is
similar to why we don't do randomized
controlled trials about smoking while
pregnant right you could say listen I
don't know that smoking while pregnant
is actually bad in order to say smoking
while pregnant Is bad we should take a
thousand women we should have a hundred
not smoke at all we should have a
hundred smoke a pack a day and a hundred
smoke two packs a day okay and then we
spend 20 years seeing what is the impact
on those kids okay that would be
horribly unethical because of what we do
know it is generally considered
unethical to withhold potentially
life-saving vaccines from individuals if
they are available and proven to be
effective the vaccines that he has been
against for a long time for kids are so
effective at preventing serious illness
that how would you do such a test do you
say hey let's volunteer a bunch of kids
to go through adolescence with no
vaccines and see what happens to them it
would be insanely unethical because of
the risk that you would expose them to
you have to balance risks and benefits
and with the serious actual validated
studies that have looked into this issue
not by doing it the way he wants because
it would be hugely unethical
but by looking at it in the ways that
the CDC and others do there has been no
link established between vaccination and
autism and this is his view so now we've
got it it's not people misstating it
it's Bobby Kennedy Jr in his own words
and it's horrifying
the weather is about to start warming up
and that often means sweating and
chafing and sticking sheath is the men's
underwear that once and for all puts an
end to all of that nonsense our sponsor
sheath underwear has designed unique
boxer briefs with an ergonomic
compartment built to keep everything
separate and dry and cool and
comfortable by allowing air to circulate
everywhere it needs to be no more
readjusting all day sheath offers a huge
variety of designs and patterns over
half a million pairs have already been
sold also check out their super
comfortable bamboo t-shirts sheath has
amazing customer service super fast
shipping along with over twenty thousand
five star reviews sheath is also
actively working with multiple
non-profits that deal with mental health
and homelessness which you support when
you get sheath underwear I've had a
great EXP experience with sheath
underwear I know you will too head on
over to sheathunderwear.com Pacman and
use the code Pacman for 20 off the link
is down below